bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal de
la rédaction de tv fil 78 26 mars et
dans l'actualité yvelinoise aujourd'hui
comment prendre en charge les victimes
de violence conjugale et intrafamiliale
une réunion vient d'avoir lieu sur ce
thème à destination des travailleurs
sociaux est l'équipe de football du
ghana affronte le 28 mars le sénégal les
joueurs se préparent et notamment le
numéro 10 de l'olympique de marseille
andré ayew nous les avons rencontrés
après le titre de champion de france
junior des desserts le lycée hôtelier de
guyancourt détient maintenant celui du
meilleur maître d'hôtel de l'hexagone
avec bertrand chapelle il est l'invité
de cette édition l'église notre-dame de
maurepas a subi des dégradations le
week-end dernier vous le voyez sur ces
images le grand crucifix s'ornant
l'extérieur a été tordu le diacre de la
paroisse d'elancourt mort patrick
querrec évoque est dans les colonnes de
nos confrères du parisien un acte sans
doute anti religieux comme on a pu en
voir dans les mosquées ou les synagogues
ces derniers temps une plainte a été
déposée
à trappes ce matin les travailleurs
sociaux se sont réunis pour évoquer les
violences conjugales et intrafamiliales
un cas pratique leur étaient soumis et
puis des professionnels du conseil
général et du pôle le psycho-social du
commerce du commissariat pardon sont
venus leur apporter les bonnes réponses
comment prendre en charge les victimes
comment les accompagner et vers qui les
orientent et des violences qui reste
complexe à déterminer et à traiter il ya
de nombreux phénomènes psychologiques
qui rentrent en ligne de compte et les
situations ne sont pas aussi limpide
qu'on le voudrait la demande de la
victime peut être aussi très complexe
c'est pas forcément de déposer plainte
dans un premier temps donc il faut
l'accompagner qu'elle fasse son chemin
puisque est un phénomène d'emprise qui
est qui est très prégnant sur la victime
bertrand bertrand chapelle le professeur
au lycée hôtelier de guyancourt vient de
remporter à à chamalières dans le
puy-de-dôme la finale nationale de la
coupe georges baptiste 2015 qui
récompense tout simplement le meilleur
maître d'hôtel de l'année bonsoir et
félicitations pour cette jolie médaille
qui est horn votre cou expliquez nous le
succès du lycée hôtelier parce qu'il ya
tout de même quelques jours c'est
baptiste vial qui a remporté le titre de
champion de france des desserts junior
le lycée hôtelier entretien vraiment
cette culture de la compétition de la
gagne nike soutenue alors c'est
important pour nous les enseignants
d'essayer de faire des concours pour
mettre en avant les métiers de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration
c'est vrai que j'ai mon collègue jean
françois gauthier qui a préparé jean
baptiste vial ils ont remporté ce
championnat de france c'est vraiment une
grande nouvelle pour le lycée hôtelier
elle a encore une bonne nouvelle avec
votre victoire pour les maîtres d'hôtel
comment vous êtes préparés justement
comment on prépare une telle compétition
alors je me prépare depuis longtemps si
j'ose dire je j'ai travaillé dans des
grandes maisons
en ouverts notamment là où j'ai fait mes
études au lycée hôtelier de chamalières
là où j'ai remporté la compétition et
j'ai travaillé donc chez michel bras à
laguiole à trois étoiles michelin je
travaille chez marc meneau en bourgogne
et à travers ses différentes maisons
j'ai comme une éponge et pris le
meilleur 2 des professionnels avec qui
j'ai travaillé pour finalement
l'emporter première place devant onze
autres candidats 60 heures maître
d'hôtel au départ qui étaient inscrits
au concours prestigieux ça représente
quoi pour le grand public qu'on
comprenne un petit peu alors c'est un
concours qui existe depuis c'était la
54e édition c'est un concours qui existe
depuis donc nombreuses années et qui est
très professionnel et qui récompense les
met en avant l'excellence en salle des
métiers du les métiers du service et
c'est vraiment une compétition qui
reconnut et d'ailleurs il y avait de
nombreux maîtres de maître d'hôtel des
meilleurs ouvriers de france
pour en tant que jury de cette
compétition
comment on définit le meilleur maître
d'hôtel il ya une dizaine d'épreuves
alors il ya dix le la place et dix
ateliers qui représente un service donc
il ya la prise de commande avec un
client américain et de clients français
il ya le service préparation d'apéritif
on tire au sort un un cocktail et on
doit réaliser le cocktail parler des
produits de la connaissance des produits
le concours était orienté également sur
les produits d'auvergne donc y avait le
service de digestif une liqueur
d'auvergne il fallait bien travailler
les différentes liqueurs et crèmes
auvergnate il y avait également le
découpage du boeuf de l'aubrac un
plateau de fromages d'auvergne qui fait
les commercialise et vend des parler des
différents produits ou vernien l'effet
des épreuves locales exactement donc
c'était très très local sur l'auvergne
est également voilà des épreuves qui qui
correspondent aussi à la réalité du
métier parce que c'est ça qui est
important
aujourd'hui comment vous faites passer
le savoir plus jeunes justement personne
est aussi enseignant vous avez parlé de
votre parcours tout à l'heure et la
façon dont vous avez absorbé telle une
éponge et un petit peu dans les
différentes maisons mais aujourd'hui
vous faites passer à savoir comment ça
se passe justement alors j'essaye de
2,2
de transmettre cela du
mieux que je peux je me prépare des
élèves à des concours il ya le concours
a également la georges baptiste et qui a
récompensé un élève qui travaille chez
gilles goujon
troisième toile michelin
rien une discipline particulière
il faut rester soi même il faut être
naturel il faut
travailler beaucoup faut travailler il
faut s'intéresser faut il faut ouvrir
les livres il faut vraiment s'intéresser
à tout et ça c'est vraiment important et
le plus les plus jeunes me font
justement parce qu'ils ont une approche
un peu différente mais il y avait il ya
beaucoup de jeunes quand même qu'ils
s'intéressent il y avait quand même 250
jeunes pour cette compétition chez les
jeunes il y avait deux catégories voilà
chez les catégories jeunes et c'est
quand même ça montre qu'il ya encore des
jeunes qui sont passionnés et qui a
envie de toucher l'excellence et vous
qu'est ce qui vous a poussée au tout
début vers cette profession
ça s'est fait naturellement entre dans
un lycée hôtelier en attendant forman
ans j'ai toujours voulu faire ça j'avais
mon ma grand-mère enfin la mère de ma
grand mère qui était cuisinière j'avais
mon oncle qui est boulanger pâtissier et
j'ai toujours j'ai toujours grandi là
dedans et j'ai tout début je voulais
faire cuisiner d'ailleurs comme georges
baptiste qui était qui est né à rouen
1804 2 qui était à l'origine un
cuisinier qui ensuite a travaillé dans
les grands établissements comme au
majestic à cannes et gourou au ritz et
voilà s'est tourné vers le restaurant
comme moi et aujourd'hui j'ai remporté
la 54e édition je suis bien heureux et
j'aimerais en profiter pour faire
partager sa mes élèves et tous les gens
qui le souhaitent ça vous a apporté
quelque chose aussi en plus pour faire
passer aux élèves pour dans votre
discours donc notre façon d'être alors
pour l'instant c'est un petit peu frais
donc
j'ai eu beaucoup de compliments de
parent de mille de mes élèves depuis
leur entrée au lycée en début de semaine
peut-être qu il
ils vous regardent différemment tout cas
oui peut-être alors la suite vous disiez
meilleur ouvrier de france sans en avoir
les leurs oui j'aimerais présenter ce
concours j'ai d'ores et déjà
il ya eu d'abord la suite le conte la
finale internationale des maîtres
d'hôtel auquel je participerai quand la
date est pas défini le pays non plus on
parle de l'asie ou
de montréal ou au canada et ensuite le
concours de meilleur ouvrier de france
que j'aimerais bien entendu tenter les
concours international ce sera vraiment
différent il ya des grandes différences
en date d'un pays à un autre ou alors ce
sont des épreuves pareil ce sera des
ateliers et donc je me prépare à
l'anglais donc j'ai déjà qu'ils ont des
contacts en angleterre pour les faire
des stages pour pouvoir me préparer
en anglais
d'accès pas encore l'heure du repos
n'ont toujours pas si on veut il faut
toujours continuer il faut pas s'arrêter
si on veut progresser parce que je pense
qu'on n'est jamais on en apprend tous
les jours comme on dit je pense que
c'est vraiment la réalité alors parler
de ces concours ces différents concours
et après vous savez déjà vous voyez ou
dans 5 dans dix ans exerçait dans une
grande maison d'ailleurs à l'étranger
par une ces pages et j'ai reçu c'est
vrai depuis quelques jours de quelques
propositions
sur paris puis également dans
l'éducation nationale j'ai pas pour
l'instant c'est encore frais je prends
le temps j'ai pas encore décidé et vous
savourer cette médaille voilà merci
bertrand chapelle professeur au lycée
hôtelier de guyancourt qui vient de
remporter dans le puy-de-dôme la finale
nationale de la coupe georges baptiste
2015 qui récompense donc le meilleur
maître d'hôtel de l'année une
distinction de plus pour le lycée
hôtelier à saint quentin en yvelines
merci à vous enseigner dans l'invité 26e
semaine de la presse le collège maurice
ravel à montfort l'amaury mobilise
enseignants et élèves de 4e marque de
chevigny journaliste à tf1 est venu à
leur rencontre cet après midi pour un
échange autour de la désinformation dans
les médias les élèves ont analysé des
articles et des reportages pour se faire
une idée et du traitement de
l'information
nous journalistes de tf1 qui ça m'a mené
à venir dans des établissements pour
pour montrer ce qu'ils y faire un autre
tour on y vient pour montrer ce que nous
ont fait le plus important de ces qui
retient lui que c'est très important de
s'informer que la presse quel que soit
le média que ce soir
eux qui se moque ou leurs applications
sur leur smartphone ne sait très bien
important c'est d'avoir
c'est d'avoir accès à l'information se
renseigner et puis qui soit capable de
déterminer quelles sources d'information
leur apporte des informations fiables
qui soit capable de déterminer si un
contenu qui trouvent en ligne ou
ailleurs et fiable ou pas ça c'est
important c'est que c'est qu'ils
comprennent que tous les contenus que
l'on trouve autour de soi ne se valent
pas certains sont issus de
différentes sources il faut comprendre
quelle est la source et quelles sont les
sources quelles sont les sources fiables
quelles sont les sources non fiables
pourquoi il vaut mieux s'informer auprès
d'un grand média quel que soit le quel
que soit le support plutôt qu'une source
anonyme sur internet
reportage complet à suivre dans notre
édition de demain du sport maintenant
c'est actuellement la trêve
internationale pour les équipes de
football et l'équipe du ghana s'est
entraîné hier mais aujourd'hui également
au stade mont boron à versailles et un
reportage signé michael et demi d'euros
et william l
des stars du football à versailles la
sélection du ghana s'est entraîné
pendant deux jours au stade mont boron
les joueurs sont venus préparer leur
rencontre amicale contre le sénégal a
rendez vous programmé ce samedi au havre
ce sera le premier match des black stars
ce depuis leur défaite en finale de la
coupe d'afrique des nations contre la
côte d'ivoire le marseillais andré ayew
a foulé la pelouse versaillaise devant
une dizaine de supporters il est ravi de
faire ça il est fini le travail est
interdite collecter moi qui m'ont dit
heureux et fier il m'a parlé de ça des
gonaïves en vénétie
des bonbons comme nous et fait
travailler
un petit temps pour regarder les heures
d'un gamin comment ça se passe on fait
des photos avec jordan ayew et anglais
on a l'habitude de voir la télé mais
renvoie comme ça là c'est mieux de
super bien nous mêmes on était étonnés
parce que d'habitude y joue un plus soit
on
en angleterre ou bien aux pays bas donc
ça fait du bien de les voir ici quoi si
un autre match amical est programmé à
proximité de la région parisienne dans
les prochains mois les 'black stars'
pourrait revenir s'entraîner au stade de
mont boron de versailles
le journal revient demain vendredi aux
mêmes horaires ce sera avec catherine
mulato je vous retrouve ce soir point un
nouveau débat autour des départementales
avec les candidats du canton de montigny
le bretonneux excellente soirée